this man just added a fourth show
because his first three at Madison
Square Garden in January are already
sold out and he's in the new film green
book that is going to be released
limitedly
on Friday November 16th and widely
released on Wednesday November of 21st
it has got Oscar buzz written all over
it Sebastian Maniscalco good to see you
sir good to see you good to be here
life is good for you right now brother
is really good yeah man it's it's been a
crazy couple of years you know I've been
doing this 20 years and finally it's
kind of all coming to a head this movie
that I'm in green book is fantastic in
Viggo Mortensen an Academy Award nominee
and Marshall Ali who has been here he
won from moonlight he's in it and the
amazing thing is because it's it's a
obviously a very serious subject about
racism in the South in the 60s about
Viggo Mortensen is driving more her
Sheila Ali's character around and he's a
concert pianist trying to find spots
that are safe for him as an African
American to be interestingly enough
directed by Peter Farrelly yeah one of
the Farrelly Brothers that's amazing
yeah we were all at a award show last
night and I'm not really a comedian
I don't go do a lot of awards shows so
yeah I went solo no wife okay and which
is a problem because my wife is like the
social one mm-hmm
and I don't really do a lot of mingling
at parties you know I'm you're not
rubbing elbows
I was never that guy I was always the
kid at recess hoping someone would say
come play with us you know so that's the
way I am now as an adult I don't really
um I sit in a corner and hope someone
maybe comes up to me and talks how does
it work at an award sir
so I was talking to some of the guys
that I knew from the movie but then you
know after they go off and talk to
producer a B and C I'm bite AB are
talking to the help I'm
I good for you I always relate to like
bartender - waiter cuz that was me you
know 15 years ago so I'm rubbing elbows
with the waiter going what do you got in
the back yeah so and then I didn't know
like we won for Best ensemble so I
didn't know you got to get up there well
I didn't know like I I did am I going up
where does the ensemble end they
announced the award night you know start
buttoning my jacket ready to get up and
fairly look over to me going were you
going so the word was called and I got
kind of like a nudge from somebody
somebody hit me on the shoulder and I
went up and you know just stood in the
background so who else from the ensemble
was everybody there everybody yeah
everywhere all the actors kind of went
up and Herschel and Viggo spoke and did
you have any I mean any thoughts is
speaking come on crash I mean you get me
in front of a crowd I would love to kill
in front of this crowd right now for me
to be on stage and not talking it's like
come on so I was kind of chomping at the
bit but yeah it was it was it was a nice
evening but I don't like going to those
solo I just I don't know what I'm doing
Sebastian Maniscalco here in the
Richardson show so drunk drop a name at
this pre-ceremony
open open open bar right open bar okay
good
open bar who would who was there that
was available for you to maybe go up to
talk to that you thought maybe I'm more
comfortable talking to the help I mean
who was there and just I didn't know
that there was no there was no one I
recognize that it first started in in
the I didn't have a publicist there
right I just said no I don't need
anybody there let me just yeah I'll just
go you'll go so I didn't know it was a
big thing I mean there was like teared
photographers right normally these
things I go to they got four guys taking
photos this look like we were at the
Oscars so I have no pub
to introduce me nobody really knows who
I'm flying under the radar no one really
knows who I am
right so I come out like like the guy
before me I think was from crazy rich
Asians it looked like lightning right
right yeah with the black now I come out
it's like a piss break for the
photographer they're cleaning their lens
go home who's this guy so and then they
go Sebastian man is that ha you know no
one could spell it and you know a couple
flashes and I'm off the red carpet you
know it's funny I had a similar
experience at the Hugh Hefner roast that
Comedy Central did just a few weeks
after 9/11 Jeffrey Ross who I ran into
in the street never met him before I
bought him and I told him I did for a
living and he just on the spot invited
me to be on the dais oh wow yes so I
went now his way they put me like 90 90
seats away from the podium that Kimmel
was the was the roastmaster for at any
rate I was so far away I was to my right
was the amazing Kreskin into my left was
Frankie in the middle malcolm in the
middle' Muniz to my left and for Jackie
the joke man Martling the reason why I
bring all this up is I went through the
red carpet first and I stand there was
it was teared and I'd never been in a
tiered red carpet with the tiered
photographers before I stepped up there
a student where he took photographs next
to the trophy they were giving Hugh
Hefner that night like three light bulbs
went off yeah
then the be a supermodel wearing a
see-through bodysuit Kylie Beck's walked
up there lightening the flashbulbs go
off and as soon as the flashbulbs go off
and she's standing next to me and I'm
like kind of looking at her they
screaming could you get off this day
literally right you don't know when to
leave like you'd like is there more
coming what should I do here so it's an
awkward situation when you're someone
that
like a you know when you have large
stars doing the red carpet and then I
come out it's just it it's embarrassing
Sebastian Maniscalco here on the Rich
Eisen show Madison Square Garden
sold-out you do realize you're from
Chicago that you had the you have large
Chicago she was to fill in that building
with Michael Jordan in Madison Square
Garden
he had his double nickel 55 point game
in there that night I mean there have
been some pretty amazing things that's
got to be pretty cool for you to go to
Madison Square Garden right yeah I mean
Madison Square Garden is something I
never thought I did it wasn't on the the
vision board
you know III didn't have a goal to play
that I just have a really really great
following in that area the tri-state
area seems like you're from New York
you seem I seem like you're one of the
many people I went to high school with
Sebastian yeah yes with you I get that
often I just grew up in the northwest
suburbs of Chicago but I guess I have a
New York kind of you got a vibe vibe and
a lot of people gravitate towards me and
my family I come from an Italian family
and a lot of my comedies about my father
who's one of these kind of immigrant
crazy fathers that brought like the old
school you came from Sicily so he
brought a lot of Sicily with him to the
United States and I and and people you
know gravitate toward like del to fo
[Laughter]
that's right it's like our Jenko our
Jenko soundboard man over there so your
dad being a Sicilian and your sense of
humor like I but I'm serious I mean
there's been a lot of great Chicago
moments in that building I mean
obviously you're a Bears and there's
Bulls Blackhawks
where are you where do you fall on the
baseball side of things you know I'm not
one of these real sports heavy fan guys
it's not like if I'm a White Sox guy but
if the Cubs win okay I went to the World
Series when the Cubs were playing okay
so it's not like I'm I don't like the
other team so I cards would think you're
forgetting yeah okay absolutely I'm just
there I like anything Chicago
okay winning I'm in mmm like I threw out
the first pitch at the Mets game about a
month ago and I get online
don't you worry cago guy oh they didn't
ask me to throw out the pitch I'm gonna
go you know what I don't know so I like
these people on the internet with this
oh well yeah like I want to say it like
I don't engage I'm not that guy I don't
go fighting with people I don't know on
Twitter I got a family you know I'm not
gonna like start up with people but you
know sometimes I read these comments or
people like you know like why would you
turn down the throw out a first pitch
anywhere of course you can't do that
yeah you do that so good are you still a
bulls bears like when you do have a
moment outside of them because your
newfound father now correct yeah I'm a
father and and I'm not much of a sports
fan like I used to be I used to be like
in the newspaper with stats you know I
used to look at the column especially
when Jordan was playing on how many
minutes did he play steals all that
stuff and now as I grew older and have a
family it's just I don't have the time
to pull up I'm not in a fantasy league
and a lot of guys that back in Chicago
you know what are you doing well going
to the draft we're drafting a new draft
in your 45 bro we're drafting with
Brockman which somebody like you
Sebastian Maniscalco brings up the draft
in this light talk about having time on
your hands
this guy no kids although he's got a
live-in girlfriend now with a dog which
is as you know that's a surrogate right
okay he hates when I bring that up which
is exactly why I just brought it up
wasn't my dog we didn't get it together
okay
so all that said tell them how your
draft works so we we travel to the city
of the team that wins the Super Bowl the
previous year oh wow is that lonely
and we have no time limits so it usually
runs about eight hours
yeah that's commitment no time limit
like so somebody could sit there spent
what twenty-eight minutes trying to
figure out whether who's Brian Hartline
eighth-round
yeah some some wide receiving him Brian
Hartline took him 28 minutes in the 8th
round to choose him I would have I would
have literally it would have come to
fisticuffs with me and I don't hit
people I didn't even know there was like
a time limit like I didn't I don't know
the rules
so when you say it took 8 hours I just
thought that sort of normally dressed
it's like an hour hour of 2000 am I in
my league yeah alright ok I'm in to 90
seconds per pick okay we're going we're
going we're doing it in an hour because
we have families okay so you know you go
do you go to like a bar to do this
summons home in the basement we do it
before our weekly poker game on Thursday
nights okay
once a year we do it in an hour we're
done I hope that that works maybe for me
I don't know I'm in a confidence pool
okay you know where you give like 15 to
one as far as like oh I think New
England's gonna kill Chicago and you
give them 15 and how you doing in that
confidence pool yeah second-to-last see
kids'll ruin it
you have a newborn right hey yeah she's
a year and a half and you know she takes
up a lot of our time if I was spending
time with her I guess okay yeah she's
about we're looking at preschools for
her right now so this is this is I can't
wait to hear the comedy that comes from
this well with any comedy on preschools
I got to get in
so right now all the schools are great
fantastic like you're on the cusp and
your wife gets a call saying that you
didn't get into the school because it's
something you said in one of your shows
that'd be a great way for you to walk in
that door that day yeah I'm reserving
all my comedy on preschools until we get
accepted we get in and then all bets are
off all bets are off I am collecting a
ton of materials so your girl you are
you're locked in your diaper change and
you're doing the whole thing right yeah
I mean it's a lot different than my
father my father came in around when I
was 15
you know that's when he started talking
to me it was working that's what he was
doing you know and from like the guy
would leave at 8:00 he'd come home at
nine ten o'clock and you know we're best
friends now but he wasn't he was in
there you know playing with me it's not
not that type of guy all right so uh
let's play celebrity true or false with
Sebastian Maniscalco before we send him
on his way right here where we take a
couple of items from previous interviews
that you've conducted or sitting there
and bio pages on the Internet um I know
how much you love the Internet let's
let's do it here
[Music]
all right I believe these are all gonna
be true based in the fact that you see
you you gravitate towards the people who
are working events that you are hanging
out at an award show first up for
celebrity true or false you worked at an
Olive Garden as a teenager is it a true
sigh that's true I worked at the Olive
Garden in Schaumburg Illinois okay
right outside Woodfield Mall and how
were you well I mean what was a pretty
fantastic you were yeah okay that was
I've been a waiter now you know ten
years right pretty much I waited tables
for ten years and I just had a way with
it you know I got upset with a lot of
people I said what do you mean hey I
used to work at a high-end hotel here in
Beverly Hills used to work at the four
C's that was my next one freedom you
worked it away as a waiter at the Four
Seasons when you first yeah 1898 to 2005
I worked in the Windows lounge and
coming out here from Chicago Chicago
people like you know honest and like
they're like you know I don't know the
Beverly Hills crowd I had to adjust my
mindset you know like a woman would come
in and she'd a wine glass and she'd take
a sip she'd be like oh you have a
thinner wine glass that doesn't rest on
my lips
correct and I have to go in the back and
scream you know but what do you say them
and on the other side of things you know
when somebody says the word absolutely
to me I'm sitting there thinking this is
some very fine service yeah
and then I gotta go scream into a pillow
so yeah I thought it was a pretty good
okay and Olive Garden is well Olive
Garden so that's where I started I used
to work banquets at the Hyatt Hilton's
a lot of jobs a honey-baked am I was
glazed in ham for a while I come from a
family where there's no like vacation
off of like college when you come home
for Christmas break it's like what do
you work what are you doing
so I was glazing hams at honey baked ham
would a full you know Sudan with a torch
and I would I would glaze turkey and ham
for the holidays come home smelling like
meat my father told me undress in the
garage so I'd come in and my underwear
because he didn't want to smell the
turkey or the ham you know all cuz all
my clothes smelled like it and yeah I
was all over the map what's the biggest
tip you ever got um two grand geez guy
used to come in and drop some heavy
money I don't know what he was doing ya
know is this like a 15 20 percent tip or
just like on on a bill of like 200 bucks
leaving something that was he would come
in at he'd or a coqui give me a hundred
right that that's not this guy was in
this guy was there for about a year so
one of the stories he asked me I'm gonna
have a a meeting with some business
associates up in the penthouse this is
when I first started comedy it was three
three years in he was huh you want to
come up and do a show for us I go yeah
I'm working goes you come up during your
break do the show I want to make it kind
of special so I want to have you act
like your room service and you come in
and I don't like the order and I want to
hit you over the head with it would a
leather chair it's gonna be a breakaway
chair and I'm going I don't know if this
under like the four seasons policy I
don't even know if I could do that so I
asked my manager I go he wants me to
come up because you could go up but
don't you know don't use the chair so
I'm waiting to go up he had given me 500
cash already geez and I mean he never
called so the next day I go what
happened he goes we cancelled the
meeting I go well here's your money back
keep it so that's the way this guy was
for a year I paid I paid for a car
waiting on this guy his name was Vince
McMahon
[Music]
and Sebastian I'm so happy about your
success you're a very very funny man
like you Madison Square Garden for me is
the mecca being from New York City so
congrats and having a fourth show added
cuz your first three have since sold out
Sebastian live.com and then green book
congratulations in advance on this film
it's gonna have some legs as they say
thank you thank you hopefully I'll be on
stage at the Oscars if they ask me to
well look at you you gotta let us you
got to take a picture your gift bag sir
can't wait fantastic congratulations
again Green Book is going to be in
limited theatre engagement on Friday
November 16th and then restore LA
released wide on Wednesday November 21st
at Sebastian comedy on Twitter Sebastian
Maniscalco thanks for context for having
me the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience